Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Muchos instrumentos musicales modernos
son incómodos o voluminosos.
Algunos necesitan
un soporte o un taburete.
Pero el cajón es
un tambor, un soporte
y un asiento todo
en una caja conveniente.
Y esa simplicidad puede ser la clave
de su viaje a través de continentes
y culturas para convertirse
en uno de los instrumentos de percusión
más populares en el mundo hoy.
La historia del cajón
empieza en África Occidental,
donde los habitantes indígenas
tenían ricas tradiciones musicales
centradas en tambores y danzas.
Cuando muchos de ellos fueron capturados
y llevados a América como esclavos,
trajeron con ellos esta cultura,
pero sin sus instrumentos nativos,
tuvieron que improvisar.
Los esclavos africanos en la costa
de Perú no tenían los materiales
o la posibilidad de construir
uno de sus tambores tradicionales
como un djembe o un dunun.
pero sí tenían un montón de cajas.
No solo había muchas disponibles,
sino que su aspecto discreto
ayudaba a eludir las leyes que
prohibían tocar música a los esclavos.
Los primeros cajones peruanos
se hicieron con una simple caja
con 5 lados sólidos de madera.
El sexto lado, hecho de una capa
más delgada de madera,
se usó como una superficie para el golpe,
o más comúnmente conocido como la tapa.
Por detrás, se hizo un agujero
para liberar el sonido.
Con el desarrollo de
la cultura afroperuana
aparecieron nuevas formas musicales
y nuevos bailes como
la zamacueca, el festejo y el landó,
y el cajón se convirtió en un instrumento
musical por derecho propio.
Los primeros cambios incluyeron
simplemente doblar las tablas de la caja
para ajustar el sonido,
y con la abolición de la esclavitud
y la introducción del cajón
a un público más amplio,
llegaron más improvisaciones
y experimentaciones.
Tal vez la persona más activa en la
introducción del cajón al público europeo
fue el guitarrista flamenco
español Paco de Lucía.
Cuando estaba de gira en Perú en 1977
él y su percusionista Rubem Dantas
descubrieron el cajón
y lo llevaron a España,
reconociendo su potencial
y uso en la música flamenca.
Al estirar las cuerdas de la guitarra
por la parte interior de la tapa,
los músicos de flamenco pudieron crear
un sonido similar al redoblante.
Junto con el sonido básico
esto dio al cajón un sonido
cercano a un kit de batería.
El cajón se extendió rápidamente,
convirtiéndose en estándar
no solo en el flamenco,
sino usando en géneros como
el folk, el jazz, el blues y el rock.
Hoy, muchos de los cajones
especializados se fabrican
algunos con cuerdas ajustables,
algunos con múltiples
superficies de juego,
y otros con un mecanismo de trampa.
Pero el concepto básico
sigue siendo el mismo,
y la historia del cajón muestra
que las cosas más simples pueden
tener el potencial más increíble
si se piensan dentro y fuera de
los límites de una caja creativa.